since the start of the pandemic what was
once thought to have been a baby bust
may have actually been a baby bump a
study from Northwestern University has
found that birth rates in the U.S
declined slightly as lockdowns began in
early 2020 but rose again in 2021 to
create a net increase of 46 000 births
above pre-pandemic levels the pandemic
has been a stressful time to give birth
and deal with the challenges of becoming
a new parent but that can be tough even
in the best of times and many believe
the United States doesn't provide
sufficient time or care for brand new
moms to adjust now some are pushing for
new Solutions and new attitudes towards
this critical time of life
I love you about five weeks after her
baby was born Elena Weir checked into
Borum inside a five-star hotel in New
York City the luxury Retreat is a
getaway for new parents complete with a
staff Nursery comfortable rooms meals
and workshops now there are some babies
who have reflux all designed to help
moms and their Partners adjust to
Parenthood we go from taking care of
ourselves to completely forgetting about
ourselves or not having time for
ourselves so I think it's a big shift
and then just coming here and even being
able to physically heal to take that
time and have mental space for ourselves
again and just ease into it and just
have that support which I think is just
really nice in the U.S moms leave the
hospital one to two days after giving
birth they often don't receive maternal
support until the traditional six-week
postpartum visit abroad many cultures
prescribe a 30 to 40-day period of rest
in Korea and other places like Taiwan
it's Unthinkable not to check in to a
place like this after you give birth
suck Park and his wife Borum Nam opened
Borum earlier this year inspired by
similar Korean Retreats our mission is
really to make the postnatal care
essential and we begin doing so by
raising the awareness and start
providing a solution right through the
services that we provide but a stay like
this is Out Of Reach for most with a
price tag around fifteen hundred dollars
a night do you think it's possible that
can become more affordable absolutely
absolutely all the urban areas should
have something like this and across
multiple price points yeah we should be
able to stay a place like this for under
500 which is roughly the the price for
uh you know what a night nurse would
charge the first six weeks following
childbirth have been called the fourth
trimester a time that has lasting
physical and mental health implications
for both moms and their newborns do we
need to do a better job after a woman
gives birth in really checking in to see
how she's doing absolutely Dr Catherine
monk is a professor of medical
psychology at Columbia University one of
her focuses is maternal mental health
how prevalent is postpartum depression
yeah you know it's really prevalent in
fact 10 to 15 percent of women and that
can actually be doubled when you're
looking at women who are experiencing
poverty so it's really common she says
care for new moms is more comprehensive
and in other countries where women have
access to midwives or other Supportive
Services countries are particularly
Australia way ahead of us England has
mother baby units and then frankly
countries that have managed this
challenge of healthcare economics just
have it a bit better than we do because
there aren't so much disparities in who
has access to what kind of care based on
what kind of insurance and things like
that Medicaid the public health
insurance program for people with low
income pays for 42 percent of all births
in the U.S some states only offer
pregnancy-related Medicaid coverage for
60 days after childbirth though more
than half expanded that coverage to 12
months after the passage of the American
Rescue plan act in 2021. I decided to do
a postpartum depression
advocacy and Comedy Tour a national tour
in a bright pink 40-foot bus because I
want to get people's attention everybody
[Music]
Angelina Spicer is leading a national
campaign to lobby for better care for
new moms
I pushing my daughter out I was like I
made a mistake
my body but I lost my mind inspired by
her postpartum Journey which included a
stop in a psychiatric ward you know the
psych ward was not the ideal place for
me to be
I was the only mom there I was the only
black woman there it was a culmination
of how I felt as a mom misunderstood
depressed sad searching for Community
searching for understanding searching
for connection I thought that I was
gonna get that there I didn't get that
but what I did get was sleep
I got sleep I got meds and I got someone
every 15 minutes asking me hey Angeline
are you okay concerned about you not
just the baby
concerned about me and I needed that
when I first had Ava I went on a 10-day
vacation to this amazing Resort in
Pasadena called the licensina
psychiatric facility
[Applause]
I call it the Waldorf hysteria did you
have any hesitation of maybe I should
maybe this is one of those areas where I
shouldn't go or joke my mom told me
she's like you're gonna joke about
postpartum you're gonna joke about the
psych ward you're going to joke about
intrusive thoughts right
and I love my mom so I hesitated because
she said it and I was like well mommy
this is funny okay and big Burly dudes
are in the comedy clubs laughing and
dming me
there's freedom on the other side of
these jokes freedom to push for
Meaningful change Spicer was part of an
effort in California that got three
bills related to maternal Health passed
helping to change the screening process
and Aid those most in need the onus
can't fall on the mom's shoulders
to Rally herself to it begin to explain
the intrusive thoughts she might be
having the depressive mood that she
might be feeling the sleepless nights
the onus can't be on the mother it needs
to be on the medical professional
to initiate these conversations and
initiate the support that's out there my
postpartum depression and anxiety was
almost immediate Spicer is also working
on a documentary about her own
experiences in the spring she'll be on
the road again taking her bus and her
comedy around the country all in an
effort to erase the stigma around
postpartum mood disorders and rally for
better care for moms so where are you
now with motherhood
I'm deep in this thing
this is the dream I'm I feel like I'm
living the motherhood dream now
I felt like the cloud began to lift when
my daughter was three
and that's still a long time yeah
but now that she's seven and she has her
thing I can go back to work freely and
I'm not like pumping backstage at the
comedy club I really feel like I'm in a
Groove we are in a Groove she is my best
friend
oh
so much of this is accessibility making
it accessible to all and this is what
Angelina Spicer has been working so hard
to do make it accessible to all
affordable to all and and she is a force
and she'll find a way to get it done I
am telling you I don't know what she
jokes about it it's amazing that she
could make it it's funny she found a way
to make it funny that freedom is on the
other side of these jokes right I love
the conversation this opens up and it
makes people think and feel like they
are supported and have exactly exactly
great story